so the nominations the attention the
accolades mean what to you where do you
have that in perspective
it's so surreal you know to be able to
grab Spike Lee yesterday and talked to
him the guy who made a movie that
changed my life do the right thing but I
saw that movie it really yeah it really
made me rethink what I thought I knew
even as a young man growing up in
Philadelphia so to be in that world yeah
I remember the first time I was
nominated angel day-lewis I was in the
same category with Daniel day-lewis and
Denzel Washington and and Hugh Jackman
and it was just you know to be there
this year with Christian Bale yeah Viggo
Mortensen and rami malek you know and to
be a director now it's so surreal Oprah
to be honest I mean it doesn't make any
sense so I just try to breathe through
it be present for it and take all the
goodness second that's a great
experience in that room though because
there's no pressure no yes nobody has to
lose that's luncheon is so great for
that but the truth is it never feel you
only feel like you're a loser when
people treat you like it afterwards
that's the only downside because the
award show ends of people like they
first of all they avoid you a little bit
and then they they do say like you know
it was a good movie I was surprised I
admit that you were not nominated for
Best Director oh thank you
were you surprised by that disappointed
by that or did you just take it in
strolls with my friend I was in New York
City at a coffee shop and I looked down
at my phone and Nicole had texted me and
they said you know congratulations on
these other things but they didn't they
didn't tell me the bad news yeah you
know and I went oh wow and the first
thing I felt was embarrassment actually
oh well think about it it's a I felt
embarrassed that I didn't do my part
today I'll work on that yeah I'm at
least glad you said that because if I
were you I would be feeling some kind of
way mm-hmm about it yeah embarrassment I
went oh gosh I didn't I didn't I didn't
do my job
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]